breaking news boris johnson has sacked
michael gove just confirmed by number 10
the man who scuppered the 2016
leadership bid
ambitions of boris johnson now fired by
boris johnson
earlier today we understand michael gove
told boris johnson he thought his time
was up it appears that boris johnson has
decided that he's not going anywhere
instead it's michael gove who's had to
fall on his sword it's interesting isn't
it because we haven't heard anything
publicly from uh michael gove unlike
some of his other colleagues but as you
say this understanding that he went in
to effectively tell boris johnson the
time was up there's history between the
two men as you alluded to
do we know anything more about how the
second came about
so we know that michael gove uh went to
boris johnson privately he was trying to
avoid this kind of psychodrama that
became so iconic uh those years ago
and instead informed boris johnson that
he didn't think that he could keep going
now it's no secret that boris johnson
and michael gove have increasingly been
at odds on critical issues uh policy
issues uh in recent weeks uh not least
brexit boris johnson taking a more
robust approach than michael gave was
willing to countenance but michael gove
has been by boris johnson's side since
the start and really
campaign the referendum and throughout
the referendum campaign and in
government where he cycled in and out of
the very most inner circle there were
moments where michael gove was making
absolutely critical decisions on things
like covert restrictions and things like
that but over time uh michael goff of
course is in the department for leveling
up a department created effectively for
him uh the two have uh parted ways uh
increasingly michael gave uh sounding
less and less happy uh to allies now
what's critical uh is that michael gove
went first but he's not the only one to
to tell boris johnson to go so there's a
question about what next i can also
reveal um sophie that there is one more
resignation to come if if michael gove i
am told by senior dance resources was a
sacking there is also a resignation now
uh the person i just spoke to didn't
give the name but we know a large number
of people who went in there to tell
boris johnson the time is up some of
whom as they say as they said to me had
letters in their pocket so any number of
contenders tonight is not over in terms
of big news but at the moment michael
gove is out so when james duddridge
issued that statement to disguise john
craig referring to the fact that there
are big
appointments big ministries of state
that will be uh filled with new uh
office holders tonight uh presumably the
department for leveling up was one of
the uh departments that he was thinking
about but a dramatic moment for this
government and it's a big resolution
isn't it let's make no bones about it
you know that this is not a junior
minister uh to be sacked this is a big
big moment uh with michael grave even if
the two men have drifted apart um i
guess my question to you is is there a
point when it becomes difficult for
boris johnson to actually fill some of
the roles that are becoming vacant yes
as a prime minister in number 10 but at
the minute it doesn't really feel like
there's much of a government well it
depends how far down the parliamentary
ranks bluntly boris johnson is prepared
to go in order to fill at the senior
jobs with the promise of more money and
great prestige um but the risk of a hit
to reputation let's be blunt about it
for joining boris johnson's government
there will be some in the
360 odd conservative mps uh willing to
take the call from the prime minister he
is after all the prime minister who's
insisting he's going nowhere that comes
with the trappings of office it's a
chance to serve your country a lot of
people would be torn over that the
matter of resignation and serving your
country not a simple uh issue
for
many many mps so i think that there is
um i don't think that i think there are
probably
people willing but i think the quality
of the names
might start um might might start to you
might see people with less experience
but we're it's clear that we're on the
precipice of uh quite a defining cabinet
shake-up because if you've got uh nadine
sahari potentially staying in post the
big question next i suppose is if pretty
patel the home secretary said that she
thinks that boris johnson should go as
there have been reports then does that
also qualify for the sack we also know
that grant schatz told boris johnson
that he
thought his time was up now critically
about grant chaps he's another inner
circle figure who has been by boris
johnson's side all the way through
uh and effectively helped fight that
first vote of no confidence has had that
spreadsheet his own private spreadsheet
famous spreadsheet famous for his own
leadership campaign absolutely famously
predicting within one or two what uh
what the number is going to be of np so
we're going to vote in that first vote
in their conference grant shaps is
saying you don't have the numbers prime
minister that's a pretty big moment just
because of the loyalty grant chaps has
shown
up until this point
but do these people
having gone in prepared to threaten uh
their resignation uh then follow through
with that threat or in the face of boris
johnson staring them down and what we
understand is boris johnson is making a
very punchy argument he is saying i'm
going nowhere you're going to have to
drag me out sure there are parliamentary
processes that we can use but i'm i'm
intending to reboot the party two things
i think uh are gonna happen you're gonna
have uh a reshuffle but you're also
going to have this dangling uh by boris
johnson of an economic plan that is code
for the kinds of tax cuts that so many
conservatives wanted but rishi sunak
wasn't keen on when he was chancellor
because that would have mean basically
borrowing uh to fund them uh now with
rishi sunak gone effectively
can nadine zahawi start spraying public
money in order to shore up boris johnson
and bluntly nadine is a harley not a man
without ambition of his own
so could we see actually the um
the economic direction of this country
starting to alter in favor of something
even more populist boris johnson
questioned on this of course earlier
today at the liaison committee didn't
deny that we could see a bit of a change
of direction it's interesting isn't it
because it's very difficult not to look
through the lens of all of this
about who could be the next leader to
take over from boris johnson because yes
he is defined he says he's not going
anywhere but of course as everyone knows
it may not be his decision at the end if
the 1922 committee do convene to change
the rules and so on so let's talk about
leadership for a bit shall we we saw of
course such a javed give what sounded to
many like a leadership pitch in his
resignation speech earlier today we
talked about nadeem zahawi
michael gaber is a bit of an operator
isn't he and perhaps his own leadership
ambitions may have been quashed but he
certainly strikes me as the kind of man
who now is on the back ventures could be
involved in some of the maneuverings
that are almost certainly going on yes
because there's been so much turmoil
over really that all the years back to
2016 there are an awful lot of king
makers uh on the conservative back
benches michael gove is one he's well
connected in parts of the party of
course uh legit contender himself gavin
williamson probably not in the race but
again will be seen as somebody pulling
strings behind uh the scene um but when
you get to it there's a question uh
about who the main contenders might be
nadim tahawi i think is one uh but
you've also got a question who will
represent the right could that be uh
potentially sowella bravement steve
baker was today talking about throwing
his hat in the ring and then from the
other wing of the party jeremy hunt
former health secretary also a
leadership contender although he
wouldn't do that well recent polling
suggests
when we get to this contest it's going
to be a huge field it's going to be
incredibly messy to find the direction
the conservative party that's possibly
why we do have some nerves about mps
pressing the button going into it
fascinating stuff sam thank you very
much for bringing us that breaking news
uh sam coates there with the line that
michael gove has been sacked